we've always been a huge 12 personnel
team
ever since pittsburgh uh that's our base
offense and uh if those are the best
matchups
then that's that's where we're ahead
each week is finding out the best
matchups you know
i love 13. i love three tight ends out
there
we have the package if you if you don't
know how to stop it it can hurt you
bruce erian's talking about his
offensive plans in tampa bay and of
course 12 personnel that means one
running back two tight ends when you've
got three great tight ends or one really
great tight end another one who has
dramatically overachieved and another
one who is underachieved but is still
not bad on your roster it's easy to go
12 personnel and big cat when you
consider what that 12 personnel looks
like ronald jones at running back mike
evans chris godwin at receiver rob
gronkowski oj howard at tight end the
third one cameron breit who will be part
of that mix
that's a pretty impressive group for tom
brady slightly better than the skill
position players he had around him in
new england last year
yeah that's gonna be watching uh tom
brady throw it to mike evans is what i'm
really looking forward to because that
type of big receiver he hasn't had in a
while uh but yeah that's a that's a
pretty impressive group and the bucks
defense uh was was pretty good last year
too they were they were stingy defense
at times so if you're bucks fans shout
out stephen shay you're probably feeling
uh pretty good going into this season i
saw peter king ranked him fifth overall
in his power rankings that's probably
that's probably about right i mean they
they haven't proven anything they have a
lot you know it's going to be i'd say
the biggest issue is that you have a guy
tom brady going to a new offense but i
would assume bruce arians can figure
that out pretty quickly and let him do
whatever he's comfortable with but new
receivers and working with them and
getting that trust level up amidst a
pandemic so that would be
uh you know the biggest issue going into
the next season for the bucks is trying
to get everyone on the same page but if
you had to pick one guy who get everyone
on the same page wouldn't you say it's
tom brady
he's already doing it he's already doing
it they got they got helmets they got
buccaneers helmets working out in a park
in tampa so he's already having football
practice even at a time when players
can't go to the facility other teams
that may have better
groups of five you know i've i i've
identified a few let me run a couple by
either the chiefs obviously when now
they don't have two tight ends but
they've got travis kelsey and they've
got three receivers it could be well
tyree kill's great sammy watkins great
mikal hardman could be joining that
group and then at running back you put
in clyde edwards hilaire or damian
williams you've got a pretty good group
i was gonna say you could go two wide
receivers two two running backs in a
tight end with the chiefs they have just
skill all over the place so i mean it's
no surprise they won the super bowl but
i i think they were the team they're the
team that pops off in my head right away
uh what other teams you had i actually
mike
your minnesota vikings are still up
there
somewhat right i mean they they they
probably are missing they're gonna miss
stefan diggs but they have the tight end
and kyle rudolph they have the running
back in dalvin cook they still have adam
theon like they they have some nice
skill positions and the other one that
popped in my head was uh the cowboys
that might be lacking at the tight end
but you add cd lamb amari cooper
and uh and that team is gonna be down
explosive mike underrated
with the vikings too irv smith irv smith
the other tight end if they do the 12
personnel in minnesota irv smith is a
guy that is going to be far more likely
to pick up a lot of the catches that
would have gone to stefan diggs instead
of justin jefferson the first round
picket receiver one more the saints
alvin kamara and latavius murray jared
cook michael thomas emmanuel sanders
throwing deontay harris for good measure
he's the guy that got behind the vikings
defense in the playoff game and caught
the pass from taysom hill you know i'd
get a taste
in there take some hills
yeah that's right he's part of the five
yeah what are you doing uh you could
also do the ten personnel with uh where
the bears have all ten of their tight
ends out there at the same time that's
my favorite so they have to be in the
conversation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports